conditional probability is an absolutely
basic idea that we use all the time it's
the probability that some event occurs
given certain information about it for
example an insurance company wants to
know what's the probability that you'll
live for the next ten years given your
medical history or a typical investor
wants to know what's the probability
that the stock is going to rise given
its stock price gyrations for the past
month there are people who actually
think you can do that that the Chartists
that not knowing anything about the
nature of the company or the business
that this that the stock is part of that
just by watching the the price gyration
you can make a better guess on what the
stock will do tomorrow than you could
otherwise another good example is for a
system engineer what's the probability
that the system is going to overload
given the recent history of the rate at
which requests have been coming in and
finally as a a joke that I like to think
about is what's the probability that
you're a cat owner given that you're
sitting in the cat section of the angel
memorial veterinary hospital okay so
let's look concretely at a very simple
example of conditional probability
that's meant to be illustrative where we
look at a die and rolling a fair die
okay now if I'm thinking about an
ordinary fair die I've got six outcomes
that are equally likely the outcomes are
one two three four five six and if I ask
what's the probability that in one roll
I roll a one well it's gonna be the
number of outcomes involving my rolling
one divided by the total number of
outcomes it's 1/6 the probability of any
given face of a six-sided fair die is
1/6 but suppose I give you some
additional information knowledge about
the role can change the judgment of
probabilities suppose that I tell you
that I rolled an odd number and now I
want to know what's the probability that
I rolled it one and the answer will now
be that given that that it's an odd
number the only possibilities are one
three and five and so the probability
has changed to one-third you know that
should be a straightforward enough idea
let's look at it though one way to
understand conditional probability as as
a kind of experiment where first you try
to roll an odd number and then you you
decide what final roll you're going to
make let's look at that tree if we were
describing it that way so the first
branch of the tree that we'll use to
build a probability space is to say okay
among the six possible outcomes what are
the chances that we rolled an odd number
well it's 50/50 because there were three
of each so there's a half chance that
yes you rolled an odd number in which
case those are the possible outcomes or
a half chance that no you didn't roll an
odd number and the possible outcomes
then or two four and six now once you're
here with one three and five
let's ask whether you roll two one the
probability that you didn't roll one
we've already agreed as one-third it's
one it's equally likely to be any one of
those three outcomes which means that
it's 2/3 that you wind up rolling either
a three or a five and likewise here the
probability if you didn't roll an odd
number that as you rolled an even number
the probability that next you'll roll a
one is zero or that you won't roll a one
is probability one so this is a kind of
standard way that we have of trying to
build up a set of probabilities for
outcomes and if we look at this tree
well first of all we can use it to
assign some probabilities because the
probability of your rolling a one is 1/6
as it should be it's 1/2 times 1/3 which
is the usual way we would calculate the
probability of this outcome by the way
we could calculate the probability of
the outcome being 3 or 5 it would be 1/2
times 2/3 or 1/3 and finally the
probability of rolling an even number
would just be 1/2 1/2 times 1 now what's
going on here well if you look at this
number 1/3 it is what we said was the
probability of
one given that you rolled an odd number
so that's where this label came from
likewise this number 2/3 is the
probability that you didn't roll a 1
given that you rolled an odd number and
finally this number is the probability
that you didn't roll a 1 given that you
rolled an even number and it's certain
all right let's do another example to
set get this idea of course let's go
back to Monty Hall which we've seen
before
remember how we have these label the
probability labels on these branches
which we figured out so if we look at
this number 1/3 what is it well this is
where where the prize is at location 1
and the contestant has picked door 1 and
that 1/3 we figured out that once the
prize is at door 1 in fact it whatever
wherever the prize is the probability
that the contestant will pick one is 1/3
this number 1/3 is the probability the
contestant will pick one and given that
the prize is at door 1 yeah
here's another third this is similarly
the probability that the contestant will
pick door 2 given that the prize is at
door 3 that's symmetric to this one but
here's something a little bit different
here's a half this is the probability
that door 3 will be open by Carol given
that the prize is it one that's that
branch and the contestant picked one and
when the prizes of 1 and the contestant
picks one Carol we said in our model is
equally likely to open the two possible
doors that have goats that she's able to
open and so that's 1/2 is this
conditional probability the probability
that she'll open door 3 given this that
were in this location in the tree given
that the prizes at one and pick isn't
one so the point is simply that we were
reasoning about conditional probability
in the very way we began defining the
tree model that we were using to define
probability spaces in the first place
we were implicitly using conditional
probabilities to label the probabilities
that left each vertex of the tree
and in fact formally speaking what we
were using was the product rule which is
that the probability that an a event
occurs and a B event occurs is simply
the probability that the a event that's
the first branch of the tree times the
probability of B given a okay and that's
the fundamental rule of conditional
probabilities that's the product rule
and it's something to be memorized now
in fact this product rule is not a
corollary it's really the definition of
conditional probability so all of the
previous discussion was motivation of
the following definition if a and B are
events in a probability space the
probability of B given a is defined to
be the probability that a and B occur
the problem that is a intersection B
relative to the probability of a so
that's the formal definition so so this
formal definition justifies the product
rule by definition because you just
multiply both sides by the probability
of a and you get probability of a time's
the probability of B given a as the
probability of the intersection notice
that implicit in this definition is the
probability of a better not be 0 so you
can't conditioned on an event that has
zero probability probability of B given
a is only defined if probability of a is
positive okay
the if you have a tree that's of depth 3
then you need a product rule for three
consecutive choices and it generalizes
in a straightforward way namely the
probability of a and B and C the first
branch is a and the second branch is B
in the third branch is C is the
probability that you do a on the first
branch times the probability that you do
B on the second branch given that you
did a on the first branch and times the
probability that you do see on the third
branch given that you did a on the first
and B on the second and this is this
product rule for 3 could in fact be
proved simply by substitution using the
product rule for 2 twice and of course
it generalizes to any finite number of
sets
it's useful to think another useful way
to think about probability that may be
more intuitive than the idea of choosing
to whether or not to roll odd and then
choosing to roll whether or not to roll
a one usually what you think of as you
roll the dice and then you're giving me
some information about what that role
was I don't think about the odds of
rolling odd or not I just tell you it's
odd and now tell me what is the
probability that among the those odd
outcomes it was one so a way to
formalize that is you can think of
conditioning on an event a as defining a
new probability function on the sample
space once you're given that a occurred
I can now think that all the
probabilities of the sample of the
outcomes have changed so in this I'll
define a new probability measure
relative to a where all the outcomes
that are not in a are going to be
assigned probability 0 because they
can't happen given that a occurred and
all of the probabilities of outcomes of
points in a just they get their
probability relative raised in
proportion to a because now a is gonna
be the whole probability space let's be
a little bit more formal about that to
be precise we're gonna define a new
probability function probability sub a
on the same sample space where the
probability of an outcome is 0 if the if
the outcome is not in a and it's it's
old probability relativized to the
probability of a if omega is n a so
that's the definition of the probability
with respect to a of Omega it's a new
probability measure on the same sample
space so to verify that this new thing
is a probability space you have to
verify that the sum of the outcomes of
the outcome probabilities is 1 and
that's a little exercise that I would
encourage you to stop now and work out
on a piece of paper because it's trivial
but it's worth checking that you follow
the definitions the claim is simply that
this new measure probability sub a
you
hey we'll satisfy all of the rules of
probability because it is a probability
measure so for example I have the
difference rule restated for conditional
probabilities given that the this that
probability sub a is a probability
measure it satisfies the difference rule
which means when I translate it into a
conditional probability statement I get
that the probability of B minus C given
a is equal to the probability of B given
a minus the probability of B
intersection C
given a it's exactly the same as the
standard difference rule except that I
have made everything conditioned on a
and so we automatically get all of these
rules for conditional probability that
we had holding for probability which
will be helpful we won't have to think
about proving them again